bonjour et bienvenue pour ce stop
science consacrée aujourd'hui à
l'évolution de ne plus fidèles et amis à
quatre pattes
jamais aucun animal n'aura eu autant
d'affluence sur l'histoire de l'homme
avec un grand h transport communication
agriculture chasse nourriture est
évidemment guère
il est incontestablement le meilleur
compagnon de l'homme il s'agit bien
évidemment du cheval et oui désolé par
avance et pour nos êtres canard même si
l'amour dans le coeur d'un bon gros
toutou est le plus grand qu'ils soient
les plus grands empires n'ont pas été
fondée à dos de chiens le cheval equus
caballus est l'une des espèces les plus
fascinantes qu'il soit déjà c'est
certainement l'espèce où il existe le
plus de balles habilités de taille d'à
peine quelques dizaines de kilos pour le
falabella et le miniature pouvant
descendre jusqu'à 2 ou 3 kilos chez les
spécimens atteint de nanisme jusqu'à une
idée ni pour les plus gros chevaux de
tri il existe 300 races de chevaux
reconnu mais malgré cette diversité très
peu de chevaux peuplent notre planète
rendez vous compte il n'existe que 54
millions de chevaux dans le monde
c'est mille fois moins que les poules
qui sont elles 52 milliards
le cheval comme la noue le zèbre
appartiennent au genre et crous et
forment donc ensemble la famille des
équidés
il est important de savoir que s'ils ont
tous un ancêtre commun sauvage la
domestication du cheval et de l'âne
n'ont rien à voir car ce sont des
espèces très différentes
en effet on divise généralement les
équidés en deux groupes d'un côté les
zèbres et les âmes sauvage l'hydre honte
l'hémione aussi appelé onagre et le kg
ang ainsi que les ânes domestique qui
forment la famille des équidés nom n'est
qu'un car ils sont génétiquement plus
proche les uns des autres qu'ils ne le
sont du cheval domestique
on y voit aussi le zèbre kwaga récemment
disparu le cheval domestique ou cheval
au sens strict du terme fait partie de
la famille des équidés et qu'un les
chevaux pour ainsi dire les vrais
chevaux avec d'autres chevaux sauvages
comme le tarp en épouse furious et le
président ce qui est cru ce prêche à
skis attention le tarp en est une espèce
de cheval sauvage totalement éteinte le
dernier tard porcs sauvages est mort en
1851 et le dernier spécimen en captivité
cet état en 1919 ainsi les chevaux
encore vivants aujourd'hui ont qualifié
à tort de tarp en son sol et précieux à
ce qu'ils soient des polices conique
mais pas de vrais tarpans pur beurre est
comme ça devient un peu n'importe quoi
alors on va dire que le mot cheval ne
désigne que les chevaux domestiques
parce que si cheval ça désigne tous les
équidés et cas alors on va pas s'en
sortir
non celle ci est anglais a maintenant 12
sorte les équidés la structure de la
patte avant du cheval en fait ça
marcherait pas derrière aussi mais elle
revient en choisir une
nous donne de précieux renseignements
sur les origines des chevaux on y
reconnaît en effet tous les constituants
typique d'une main classique le radius
cubitus les os du poignet puis de la
main qu'on appelle métacarpe ti les
phalanges c'est à dire le droit
ainsi le symbole du cheval est une sorte
d'ong ou de glaise plate si vous voulez
ce qui nous montre que dans un lointain
passé
les chevaux ont dû posséder un ancêtre
qui avait cinq doigts cette prédiction
est presque parfaitement soutenu par la
découverte en angleterre dira qu terium
un petit équidés aux mains pleines de
doigts
et devinez qui c'est qu'il a découvert
un indice c'était en angleterre
non c'est pas vrai encore lui oui il est
partout il étudie tous mais il vous
regarde c'est ça ricciardo owen
au fait tu as dit presque parfaitement
pourquoi presque
ben si je dis presque parce qu'il n'a
que quatre doigts pas cinq mais un autre
animal fossiles un peu plus anciens
fenaco du ce de 50 millions d'années
posséder cinq doigts et pourrait
constituer un très lointain cousin des
équidés donc on découvrira peut-être un
jour l'ancêtre à cinq doigts des équidés
mais en attendant vous pouvez toujours
regarder les petits doivent roenick
thuel des chevaux d'aujourd'hui qui sont
sur le côté de sa patte noté l'ex de
symétrie de la main qui passe alors au
droit du milieu
ce caractère définit les paieries sow
dactyle une super famille de mammifères
herbivores qui rassemble les chevaux
avec tenez vous bien les tapirs et les
rhinocéros et ce n'est pas tout chez les
personnes actives il y avait aussi
autrefois les bretons terre les calicots
terre et sorte de show gogo ville et les
adrie koster qui ont largement dominé le
paysage il ya plusieurs millions
d'années avant que les ruminants des
prennent leur place
l'abricot terre par à ceyrat terium
parfois connu sous le nom de ballouchy
période et par exemple le plus grand
mammifère qui ait jamais vécu et
regarder qui fait même une petite
apparition dans les films et de noé irak
antérieure était à très petits d'équidés
et le plus ancien ce n'est pas pour
autant qu'il faut en conclure que
l'évolution des équidés soit une ligne
droite conduisant d'une espèce de petite
taille a une espèce de grande taille
c'est un peu simpliste et franchement
réducteur l'histoire évolutive des et
qu'il y est un peu plus complexe
voilà là c'est un peu mieux et un peu
moins l'hiver
bon c'est bon vous avez eu le temps de
tout lire alors on continue donc
l'histoire de l'évolution des chevaux
n'est pas un long fleuve tranquille mais
un arbre plein de ramifications durant
toute leur existence depuis près de 55
millions d'années le centre de
diversification des équidés a toujours
été l'amérique du nord
là les espèces naissait se développer
avant de traverser l'atlantique vers
l'eurasie via le détroit de béring ou
bien encore le détroit de panama vers
l'amérique du sud
mais la nature ne manque pas d'humour et
très ironiquement il ya un peu moins de
dix mille ans à la fin du dernier âge
glaciaire les équidés s'éteignent
d'amérique du nord ne survivant plus que
dans les continents périphériques
rendez-vous quand c'est comme si l'homme
disparaissait d'afrique
ne vous en faites pas les équidés non
pas pour autant complètement disparu de
la surface du globe
ils ont
je réinvestis à leur continent d'origine
grâce à l'homme
c'est pourquoi aujourd'hui tous les
chevaux sauvages parcourant les grandes
plaines d'amérique du nord sont
descendants de chevaux domestiques des
egos kabalu justement où quand et
comment s'est produite la domestication
du cheval au risque de nous répéter la
domestication du cheval a été faite
indépendamment de celle de l'âne mais
l'un comme l'autre sont fort semblable à
leurs pendants sauvage et font donc
parti des dernières conquêtes domestique
de l'homme les premiers chars découvert
en ukraine un test de l'utilisation du
cheval comme animal de trait il ya entre
4000 à 5000 ans par les sites et la
découverte récente en chine d'un
pantalon de cavaliers renforcée entre
les jambes suggèrent fortement que le
cheval a été domestiqué dans les grandes
plaines sèche d'asie centrale
qu'on appelle plus couramment des
steppes même si on sait pas s'il était
déjà domestique ou encore un peu sauvage
les cheveux deviennent par ailleurs très
abondant dans les sites archéologiques
de ces régions steppiques à partir d' il
ya 6000 ans ce qui suggère que le cheval
est devenu un animal prépondérant du
quotidien des hommes à partir de cette
époque
voilà donc le cheval il a été domestiqué
ici la raquette par sur cette bande de
vertain d'à peine euros 7000 km de long
quoi ça va ça réduit la zone doc
sunshine ou non comment ça non
bon bon d'accord bas en tout cas c'est à
partir de quelque part par là que ça
commence quoi autrefois c'était
l'ukraine qui était pointé du doigt
comme étant le lieu d'origine du cheval
domestique mais la datation plus précise
des gisements et des découvertes plus
récentes place désormais l'origine du
cheval plus à l'est au kazakhstan c'est
en effet la conte et des découvertes les
toutes premières traces d'une
utilisation domestique du cheval
remontant à 5500 ans de façon très
surprenante les analyses chimiques du
conduit des poteries du site de bataille
ont montré que le but de la
domestication de ses chevaux n'étaient
pas de les monter mais d'exploiter le
les nuls
il faut dire que les chevaux sauvages
comme le che walsky actuels ont la
réputation d'être
d'opa rouge
on a aussi retrouvé des traces de
sacrifices rituels de chevaux dans la
même région sur les rives de la volga
remontant à 7000 ans donc la
domestication des chevaux a bien eu lieu
dans cette zone géographique et 7 à
partir de là que les chevaux se sont
répandus à travers le monde et avec eux
toute la civilisation indo européenne
qui unit les cultures depuis la pointe
de l'europe jusqu'à l'extrême orient
cette domestication a apparemment eu
lieu dans une fourchette de taux
comprise entre 6000 et 7000 ans ça c'est
un radeau certes oui mais de toute façon
c'est inutile de vouloir chercher un
lieu et une origine unique pour le
cheval on va vous dire pourquoi mais
d'abord il faut que vous sachiez ce
qu'est la paléogénétique en effet quand
les paléontologues se penche sur les
fossiles d'équidés récent il tombe pour
ainsi dire sur un nuage gris et pas des
moindres comment reconnaître un zèbre
d'un cheval quand on a que le squelette
autrement dit il est difficile de dire
si telle ou telle espèce fossile est
plus proche du zèbre ou du cheval quand
on voit pas ses rayures en plus les
chevaux domestiques a été le montre à
quel point la morphologie peut être
variable chez un équidé à partir de là
beaucoup de paléontologues ont bloqué
sur la question de l'origine et de la
diversification des équidés et de
l'origine des chevaux domestiques dans
tout un fatras disgracieux d'espèces
fossiles plus méconnaissable les unes
que les autres
heureusement la paléontologie à papy
c'est fini la manche au logis du
squelette c'est bien mais pour assister
le paléontologue de demain il y à l'audi
des paléontologues 2.0 l'adn ancien
aujourd'hui on sait extraire des
quantités parfois infimes da dnd houde
et non une espèce éteinte de l'adn de
fossiles c'est presque jurassic park en
vrai c'est une prouesse technique car
autrefois on pensait que le minéral
remplacer totalement le biologique dans
les fossiles qui ne pouvaient par
définition plus contenir ddm mais les
études paléogénétique ont montré que
c'était faux évidemment extraire de
l'adn noces de cheval ou de n'importe
quoi d'autre d'ailleurs
ça ne se fait pas sans peur et bien
souvent il faut au moins couper sinon
réduire en poussière notre fossiles afin
d'en extraire la précieuse information
génétique
c'est le prix à payer pour être sûr de
ne pas ramasser l'adn de quelqu'un
d'autre sur la surface de l'os le plus
vieil adn d'une espèce fossile a
justement été extraite d'un os dès qu'il
est préservée dans le soap jeu et
d'alaska par l'équipe d'un pionnier en
la matière
ludovic orlando or rien de plus on se
dit mais vous appréhenderez la nana na
na ludovic orlando un généticien
français originaires de marseille et
travaillant à l'université de copenhague
par comparaison la vienne le plus ancien
pour sa part venus extraire d'un homme
des cavernes un prêt néandertaliens est
presque deux fois moins vieux il dette
de 400 mille ans seulement pour l'ours
des cavernes
c'est 300 mille ans et on est loin des
millions d'années qu'il nous faudrait
pour ressusciter un t-rex
en plus ce serait complètement
impossible car le plus souvent les paléo
généticien utilise une partie infime de
l'adn l'adn mitochondrial pour leur
analyse c'est à dire l'adn de tous
petits organites contenu par dizaines
voire même par centaines dans nos
cellules et qui sont responsable de la
synthèse de notre énergie
le grand nombre de ses mitochondries à
l'intérieur de cellules augmentent leur
probabilité de résisté aux outrages du
temps et la petite taille de leur code
génétique rend plus facile la lecture de
leur adn car ce dernier est présent en
autant de copies qui lie à demi seconde
bref ce n'est généralement qu'un tout
petit bout de l'adn d'une espèce qui est
exploitable par les paléo généticien et
c'est le plus souvent l'adn
mitochondrial or pour cloner un
dinosaure mais il nous faudrait la
totalité de l'adn non pas mitochondrial
mais nucléaire qui lui n'est présent
qu'en une seule copie dans le noyau de
la cellule
autant dire que c'est pas gagné
et d'ailleurs ce n'est pas la chose la
plus intéressante à faire des points de
vue scientifique avec de l'adn nucléaire
et oui quand on parvient à extraire de
l'adn provenant d'un noyau d'une cellule
le fameux adn nucléaire
ce dernier peut nous apprendre beaucoup
de choses comme par exemple que les
mammouths et est capable de produire de
l'antigel lui permettant de résister au
froid ou encore que l'homme de
néandertal était plutôt blond et rouet
la peau blanche
c'est tout aussi fun qui est bien plus
réaliste que clooney les dinosaures non
mais revenons à nos chevaux l'adn
mitochondrial anciens bien en complément
des caractères squelettique de la
paléontologie classique voire même à sa
rescousse dans le cas des équidés
pléistocène
et oui les équipes qu'ils soient et
qu'un nom n'est qu'un ont divergé entre
4 les 2 millions d'années et chacune de
ces deux sous famille comporte des
représentants fois ci complètement états
qui sont difficiles à différencier est à
replacer dans ces deux familles
mais par exemple grâce à l'adn ancien on
sait aujourd'hui que le très célèbre
kwaga à un équidé qui cet état en 1878
était en fait un zèbre donc un équidé
n'en est qu'un on sait aussi que la
famille des équidés icain c'est à dire
des chevaux vrais comptait autrefois
bien plus d'espèces sauvages en
particulier en amérique avant qu'il ne
s'éteigne complètement il y a dix mille
ans il y avait le cheval d'amérique du
sud
lippi lyon aux membres cours est robuste
et au large mais parfaitement adapté à
la rude vie dans les montagnes des andes
ou au contraire il y avait la mairie
puce un cheval sauvage quand on pensé
qu'il était plus proche des haines et
mione en se basant sur les ses longues
jambes gracile parfaite pour gambader
dans les grandes plaines nord américaine
mais l'adn ancien a révélé que c'était
bien avec l'idée est qu'un ce quand même
dommage on est vraiment passés pas loin
d'avoir une diversité surprenante de
chevaux sauvages
alors maintenant comment la
paléogénétique nous aident à résoudre le
problème de l'origine du cheval
domestique en tant que dernier
représentant des chevaux sauvages le
cheval de przewalski qui n'est à ce
propos pas polonais mais mongole est
souvent présentée sans autre forme de
procès comme l'ancêtre des chevaux
domestiques
rien n'est plus faux pour rappel le
cheval de przewalski est une race très
spécial connu pour son aide massive
il ne se laisse pas monter comme ça en
plus le cheval de przewalski semble être
arrangé bien à part du cheval domestique
et égard à son nombre de chromosomes
en effet les espèces dekhili se
distingue tout par leur nombre de
chromosomes très différents les uns les
autres et le cheval de przewalski
possède une paire de chromosomes en plus
par rapport au cheval domestique noter
que toutes ces espèces ou presque toutes
sont capables de s'y brûler entre elles
et de donner des descendants et ce
malgré des différences de nombre de
chromosomes pouvant aller du simple au
double néanmoins la plupart du temps les
descendants seront stériles s'offrant
qu'elle avait atteinte à temps j'essaye
de celle de 7 à l'aube chez valls qui
est le cheval ne peuvent pas donner de
descendance fertile cadres comme ils
n'ont pas de même nombre de chromosomes
pas du goût de chromosome 18 et venant
du cheval de przewalski il va se
retrouver tout seul
et alors là bas ça ça fait que ces deux
espèces mais non non non non justement
j'avais dire que dans le cas des chevaux
domestiques et des pièces qui ils
peuvent s'accoupler donner des
descendants fertile que les chevaux de
przewalski d'aujourd'hui ont été sauvé
in extremis de l'extinction dans ceux
des spécimens gardés en captivité dans
des parcs et des eaux
ils sont tous descendants une population
d'à peine 13 individus ne contenant que
quatre semaines et on sait que l'un de
ces individus au moins était un cheval
domestique ont un hybride avec un cheval
domestique
donc les deux peuvent si bonne idée même
s'ils n'ont pas le même nombre de
chromosomes et ça c'est grâce à la
transformation robertson yen à quoi la
translocation robertsauvienne quentin
chase qui est un cheval domestique
s'accouplent les bras les plus longs de
deux chromosomes accroc centric vont se
détacher puis fusionné l'un avec l'autre
pour former un seul et unique super
chromosomes les bras courts seront
éliminés et de cette façon il n'y aura
pas de prendre une solitaire ni de
risque de trisomie
non mais attends mais si c'est
complètement dingue ton truc c'est ultra
puissant deux chromosomes et il n'en
reste plus qu'à mais que comme on
appelle ça déjà translocation roberto
niel
bon d'accord les chevaux de przewalski
sont peut-être de la même espèce que le
cheval domestique ou pas mais ça ne le
dit pas pourquoi les ne sont pas leurs
ancêtres pour répondre à cette question
va falloir faire un petit détour par la
notion d'horloge moléculaire un
processus qui permet de dater l'origine
des espèces sans l'aide de faux cils ou
presque
comment si tout simple vous prenez l'adn
de deux espèces vous comptez le nombre
de différences entre l'adn des deux
espèces dont qui s'il y en a deux et
sachant la vitesse à laquelle les
mutations de l'adn ont lieu d'une
génération à une autre
vous pouvez déterminer le temps pendant
lequel ces espèces ont évolué
chacune de leur côté est donc donné leur
date d'origine à quelques milliers ou
millions d'années près c'est un badge
moléculaire permet de donner une
estimation de la dette d'origine de
certaines espèces plus ou moins
indépendamment des syndiqués par les
fossiles bien que généralement
l'utilisation de dalles basé sur le
registre fossile soit préférable pour la
bonne calibration préalables us de
l'horloge
c'est ainsi que les analyses
paléogénétique ont montré que l'origine
des chevaux domestiques remonte à cent
mille voire même trois cent mille au aux
attendes raison allait doucement tout à
l'heure on a des 6000 ans à tout casser
et maintenant tu lui dis que la
domestication du cheval dati gagnent une
voire plusieurs centaines de milliers
d'années
c'est quoi ces salades qui comprend plus
rien adam 6000 ans et la domestication
du cheval je n'ai pas dit que la
domestication du cheval daté d'il ya
cent mille ans j'ai dit que l'origine du
cheval domestique remonte à il ya cent
mille ans ça veut dire que le dernier
ancêtre commun du cheval avec eu très
longtemps avant la domestication du tout
premier cheval est en attente que je
résume
moi je croyais que l'on sait être commun
des chevaux étaient en fait le tout
premier cheval domestique et ya six ans
suite à l'isolément d'une population de
chevaux sauvages par les hommes mais en
gros ce que nous dit la dance et que
l'ancêtre commun du cheval domestique
n'est pas apparu si milan oui mais il ya
au moins cent mille ans et que du coup
si tout le chevaux restants au jour
sont des chevaux domestiques
s'impliquent que l'homme a procédé
plusieurs fois et sûrement à plusieurs
endroits différents à la domestication
des chevaux exact exact cette différence
très nette ce retard immense entre l'âge
supposé de l'ancêtre commun
plus de cent mille ans i les premières
traces de deux médication illustre
parfaitement le fait qu'il y a eu
plusieurs domestication ah oui il n'y a
eu qu'un seul événement domestication
alors là je lancerai être commun des
chevaux domestiques serait parfaitement
corée avec lui or ce n'est pas le cas
les chevaux domestiques sont d'abord
apparues sauvage ya cent mille ans puis
chacune de ses nombreuses lignées a été
domestiqué une par une depuis 6000 ans
seulement et ça va plus loin les
analyses génétiques basés sur l'adn
mitochondrial on a montré qu'en fait il
y a eu en tout 77 lignée de chevaux à 77
lignée du mans poids du coût qui ont été
domestiqués indépendamment en fait c'est
même plus vicieux que ça car la
diversité des gènes du chromosome y le
chromosome spécifique au mal et très
faible ce qui montre qu'il n'y a que
très peu des talons qui ont été
sélectionnés à la base qui se sont
croisés à l'excès 77 jument nos ancêtres
préféré se garder les mâles et le pool
génétique des lignes et sauvage de
chevaux a été incorporé au pool
génétique des chevaux domestiques par le
biais d'un coupe le mans sélectif entre
très peu de mal domestique d'à côté et
77 ligne et deux femelles sauvages de
l'autre évidemment il y avait beaucoup
de chevaux sauvages et tous les chevaux
du mans n'ont pas été domestiqués les
autres lignes et de chevaux sauvages qui
n'ont pas participé à ce processus sont
tout simplement éteinte et cela inclut
le tarp en est à de justesse épargné le
cheval ski c'est ainsi qu'on se retrouve
avec des séquences d adn de chevaux
sauvages en plein milieu de l'arbre de
chevaux domestiques
tenez voici le cheval de przewalski s'il
était l'ancêtre
domestique comme beaucoup le croient
alors ils devraient se brancher juste à
la base de l'arbre pas à l'intérieur
mais ce n'est pas le cas et il ya même
eu un cheval dans la séquence a été
extraite d'un os retrouvés dans le sol
gelé d'alaska planté en plein milieu des
chevaux domestiques
cela ne veut pas dire que le cheval
domestique l ancêtre du cheval sauvage
mais simplement que les chevaux
domestiques sont les seuls survivants
des multiples lignes et de chevaux
sauvages qui existait autrefois et qui
ont disparu suite à la fin de l'ère
glaciaire
alors finalement non le schéma nice qui
n'est pas l'ancêtre des chevaux et se
posait la question domestique et où et
quand impliquer une origine unique du
cheval domestique qui déjà de base
n'était pas gagné alors quoi ressemblait
l'ancêtre sauvage du cheval domestique
s'il ne s'agit pas d'âme chez valls qui
les peintures faites par nos ancêtres
dans les cavernes en montant était le
seul moyen de se faire une idée de
l'aspect de l'ancêtre des chevaux mais
nos propres ancêtres n'étant pas
dépourvu d'imagination
certaines de ses peintures sont
certainement loin de refléter les
animaux ayant pu réellement existé
heureusement une fois de plus c'est la
paléogénétique qui vient à votre
rescousse
la couleur de la robe est comme toutes
les caractéristiques du corps d'un
animal induite par des gènes et un
portrait robot de l'ancêtre sauvage du
cheval peut donc être tracé à partir de
l'histoire de ces gènes
c'est ainsi qu'il a été possible de
déterminer que dans la population
ancestrales se trouvait 76% de chevaux à
la robe baie c'est à dire bras foncé
accra noir et 24% de chevaux noirs et
louis ses cheveux ne ressemblait pas à
des chebab strict il a dit merci de leur
robe n'était pas flamboyant tu tousses
possédait aussi une red bull est c'est à
dire une ligne sombre courant le long de
leur dos que l'on retrouve aujourd'hui
chez les ânes lecce wolski ou encore les
polyphonique la diversification de la
couleur de la robe n'aurait commencé
qu'il ya 5000 ans avec la domestication
quelques parenthèses cette
diversification devient ensuite très
rapide à l'âge du bronze avec
l'apparition des tout premiers chevaux
tacheté il y a quatre mille ans c'est à
dire 20 mille ans après qu'ils aient été
inventés par les hommes de la grotte
pech-merle c'était des visionnaires en
fait oui enfin quoique la mutation à
l'origine de cette tâche a quand même
été identifiés dans l'adn paléolithique
de quelques chevaux préhistorique
démontrant justement ici qu'on a beau
connaître beaucoup de choses sur
l'ancêtre commun des chevaux il ya
encore beaucoup de zones d'ombré qui
persistent
autre exemple il n'est pas encore tout à
fait clair si la population ancestrale
de chevaux ne comprenait qu'une seule
espèce
et si cette espèce était etc aux féroces
le fameux petit arpent dont il était
question tout à l'heure et qui pourrait
être l'espèce ancestrale des chevaux
domestiques
seule une analyse paléogénétique du tarp
en permettrait de répondre à cette
question mais voilà il ne reste
aujourd'hui qu'un seul squelette de
tarpans à behren conservés à l'institut
de zoologie de saint-pétersbourg est
donc bien faut dire qu on rechigne un
peu à faire des petits trous dedans ou à
embrouiller des morceaux pour avoir son
adn l'origine et l'évolution des cheveux
concernera donc pour l'instant sa part
de mystère
mais c'est justement cela qui les pousse
ces généticiens et les paléontologues
repousser toujours plus loin les limites
de leur discipline respective
l'adn ancien n'a pas encore révélé tous
ses secrets pour en savoir plus nous
vous suggérons une fois de plus la
lecture de lentilles jurassic park de
ludovic orlando merci à tous